l'heure de ranger ses valises après 9
jours d'adrénaline à 17 ans mathieu
gotti a vécu sa première coupe du monde
de basket-ball lui qui a commencé ce
sport à l'âge de 9 ans et grandit
entourée d' idole tous les jours et de
mieux que tu m'impressionnes et à qui
vous ressemblent eu tort luis carrero
rui goncalves brook je pense mais deux
exemples sur en argentine ce berruyer de
descente s'est distingué par sa vitesse
comme ici contre les philippines en
final une défaite face aux etats-unis
après des échecs dans son adolescence
pas question de cracher sur une médaille
d'argent
j'ai beaucoup à apprendre pour devenir
le joueur que je veux être forcément
mais bon pas trop de frustrations battre
parce que c'est une bonne expérience de
jeu les états unis au final ça m'a
permis de découvrir le niveau
international
une courte carrière déjà remarqué en
décembre ses parents sont contactés par
une grande agence française à son
tableau de chasse
de nombreux joueurs tricolores qui
évoluent dans le championnat américain
une grosse grosse grosse pointure qui
sont représentés par cette agence axel
bouteille evan fournier jérémy leloup
après plusieurs mois des changes un
accord verbal a été conclu mais la
prudence reste de rigueur
on est content que qu'il soit contacté
par un agent mais en même temps
les intérêts sont tellement énormes que
qu'on a peur on a peu pour mathieu parce
qu'il est quand même mineur mais on a
peur qu'on nous mêmes de se tromper ou
de ne pas suivre les choses quoi donc on
a peur une agence qui aura sponsorisés
l'entraînement estival du numéro sept
français trois semaines de stage
direction dallas